et aujourd'hui le retour sur l'actualité
est consacré aux maisons folie créé à
l'occasion de lille 2004 lorsque lille
était capitale européenne de la culture
il y a eu douze maisons ouvertes en
général on est parties de bâtiments
industriels à l'abandon et on les a
transformés en lieux de fabrication de
spectacle ou d'art et voici ce que sont
devenus les fameuses maisons folie et de
2004 utopie ou folie une fois le rideau
tombé la question de leur survie étaient
récurrentes pour ces deux maisons folie
franco belge initié par lille 2004
si on n'y topi quelque part parce que je
pense que financièrement ces prêts
viable c'est trop lourds financièrement
pour les villes extérieures
pourtant aujourd'hui elles sont toujours
là après une saison 2005
seule celle de tournai a mis la clé sous
la porte petit tour dans la métropole
lilloise qui en compte 7
on peut dire que la raison du plus fou
l'a emporté zpux folie qu'est ce qu'il
ya derrière on est toujours qu'est ce
qu'il ya derrière la folie à ce que
c'est une folie une folie et volontaire
ou est-ce que des personnes aient
vraiment folle en tout cas faut que
j'aille vérifié et c'est ce que je sais
c'est ce à quoi j'avais ton âge il
s'agit bien d'une désacralisation de la
culture ces maisons ne sont pas des
lieux de diffusion de plus ici on
s'initie au répète on résidents créé
bref qu'on s'amuse le quartier s'en
trouve tout chambouler
maison des gens de toutes horizons des
jeunes beaucoup de discussions beaucoup
de
d'approcher des gens tirent des gens
tout métier certaines expériences comme
les résidences d'artistes qui
aboutissent à une exposition se vivent
parfois mon cours à wazemmes
christine kristoffersson venue
d'australie vient de passer deux mois
dans le loft prêté par la maison sur le
site est le résultat de son travail
vient d'être présenté c'est vraiment
intéressant des longues périodes comme
ça de pouvoir se permettre de vraiment
laisser un artiste entente qui vit
vraiment avec le quartier au rythme du
quartier et avec christine ça vraiment
produit des rencontres assez insolite
elle est partie par exemple c'est il ya
un atelier de cuisine à la maison de
quartier elle a sympathisé avec ces
femmes qui sont venus après avoir son
expo justement faire venir des personnes
qui n'auraient jamais eu envie de
pousser les portes de la culture c'est
un départ et de ses maisons folie où la
mixité des expressions se décline sous
tôle et auront cotisé pendant la belle
saison on organise des dimanches au bord
de l'eau même si la vocation de cette
maison folie à lambersart et d'organiser
de grandes expositions dans ce lieu
ouvert sur la nature ce qui le démarque
peut-être c'est que c'est un lieu
d'expositions temporaires ont à peu près
600 700 m² dédiés aux expos
effectivement la verrière joue aussi sur
le côté deux en dehors donc après il ya
environ sept gros projets dans l'année
d'expo on va dans tous les sens on
essaie de balayer tous les champs d'arts
plastiques mme sylla photo fa et environ
7 gros projets par an ici aucun
spectacle en diffusion mais à venir une
expo sur le toucher en partenariat avec
d'autres maisons folie et lieux de
culture de la région comme à la
condition publique
il a créé un le pcc un établissement
public de coopération culturelle qui
donc la condition publique était porté
par la ville de roubaix aujourd'hui à
des portées par le conseil régional
nord pas de calais par la communauté
urbaine de lille et par la ville de
roubaix
c'est ça le grand changement qu'il y a
eu entre 2005 et 2006 on va continuer
déjà tout ce qu'on a entamé tout le
rendez vous réguliers les bases des
beaux dimanches les concerts du jeudi
puis on va commencer avec une grosse et
expositions qui s'appelle paradis rama
qui est autour de la culture du surf et
des tiki des vahinés des cannibales on
va parler de tout ça pendant pendant un
trimestre ici dans cette salle
pérenniser les budgets fidéliser les
nouveaux publics
osez l'impossible rêve décidément ces
maisons ont de beaux jours devant elle
on peut dire l'utopie ou la folie peut
continuer sur sa lancée